hello everyone and welcome to the
mindscape podcast i'm your host sean
carroll if you spend any time on the
internet or maybe even if you don't you
probably have heard about the amazing
visual abilities of the mantis shrimp
the mantis shrimp is a tiny little guy
it's a shrimp that has probably the most
complex eyes in the entire animal
kingdom you know we human beings we have
color vision our color sensitivity is
pretty good human beings have pretty
good eyes and we have three different
kinds of cones in our eyes three
different kinds of color sensitive
photoreceptors that are the three
different kinds sensitive to slightly
different wavelengths if you're an
astronomer like i used to be it's like
three different filters that pass
different wave bands through to the eyes
so we can combine these three different
kinds of photoreceptors trichromatism it
is called to reproduce what we see as
different colors of light what we
perceive as different colors of light
now the mantis shrimp has 12 different
kinds of photoreceptors with different
sensitivities across the spectrum so it
has been in popular imagination imagined
that the mantis shrimp sees a whole
bunch of kinds of colors that we human
beings can't actually see
sadly that's not true and on today's
podcast you will learn that that is not
true uh the mantis shrimp doesn't
actually take advantage of its dodeca
chromatism or whatever you want to call
it it's actually according to
physiological tests not able to discern
even as many colors as human beings are
sorry to undo that little legend for you
but the point remains the same which is
that we use our senses to make pictures
of the world to build a model of what is
really out there and of course there's a
trivial sense in which different kinds
of animals sense the world differently
if they're sensitive to different
wavelengths of light or different
frequencies of sound but there's also a
more profound sense in which animals of
different species perceive the world in
wildly different ways because they
either have more sensory apparatuses or
entirely different kinds of sensory
apparatuses they're animals that live
off of sensing vibrations and can
basically touch things far away via
signals sent by air or water
not to mention animals that have actual
receptors to magnetic fields or electric
fields in ways that human beings just
don't have so all of these animals
really construct in their minds a very
different kind of picture of the world
than we human beings do that's we're
going to talk about today with ed yong
who has a new book out on exactly this
topic an immense world how animal senses
reveal the hidden realms around us
i've known ed for a long time
we were both briefly bloggers at
discover magazine i don't know 15 years
ago or whatever it was
since then that has gone on to great
things he's a staff writer for the
atlantic he did a lot of coverage of the
coronavirus uh kovid 19 uh pandemic and
won the pulse surprise for his coverage
of that but the book that he just came
out with is actually or i guess that
will come out tomorrow is much more
along his traditional beat of looking at
ways in which animals are both similar
to us and different to us and of course
it helps us understand ourselves to
think about the fact that we are
constructing images of the world
predicated on our sensory
access to that world but more
importantly just helps us understand
that animals are different that what it
is like to be a bat or a mantis shrimp
etc is very different than what it is
like to be a human being okay so
occasional reminder that we have a
webpage here on
preposterousuniverse.compodcast
so you can find all the old episodes of
mindscape complete with transcripts show
notes links etc links to the books like
today a link to ed's book and immense
world uh and also we have a patreon if
you would like to support on patreon you
can go to patreon.comcarol
you get to ask questions for the ask me
anything episodes which will now be
regular monday episodes going forward
and also of course you get ad-free
versions of the podcast so many ways to
experience the mindscape podcast
experience so with that let's go
[Music]
ed young welcome to the mindscape
podcast hello thanks for having me
i wanted to start by asking you if
you've ever done dining in the dark do
you know what that is
i have heard of it but i have not done
it it's when you are
you are having dinner like i feel like
it's the clues in the name right isn't
it just where you have dinner in a
completely dark room and there's like
waiters with night vision goggles
well there's waiters the way that we did
it uh the waiters were actually blind so
they were just used to getting around
without uh any vision but they turn off
all the lights it's a great scam if
you're a restaurant because you don't
need to decorate your restaurant and
also
the the gimmick is that
the rest of your sensorium becomes more
sensitive so the the food doesn't need
to be fancy it just needs to be kind of
vivid and you you taste all the
differences between the different kinds
of lettuce in your salad and so forth
and you learn to get around without
seeing things
that's interesting um was it good did
you enjoy it it was good i did enjoy it
they also come out with little games to
play to uh see if your sense of touch
has improved uh because you can't see
anything for a couple hours but
it made me think of it because it's sort
of like censorium tourism right i mean
your book is all about how different
animals experience the world in
different ways through different senses
and it just it just made me think of how
we can sort of fake that by depriving
ourselves of senses and and how the
world appears differently when we do
that
yeah
absolutely um you know i think that um
uh i
um so the book is about this concept of
the the umvelt um the idea that every uh
animal has its own sensory bubble uh and
it has its own like coterie of smells
and sights and and sounds that it can
tap into another's can't um and you know
the man who who pioneered this term um
uh jakob vernotzko um he
he thought of um
the the study of elton as an act of
travel you know as an act of adventure
and that that's what i think of when
when you talked about centaurium tourism
um that um
it is um it is sort of a wonderful
mini adventure to um to push against the
constraints of your own senses
yeah and i think that when you mention
to the person on the street that
different animals sense the world
differently there's sort of easy
examples that come to mind and hard ones
right like different wavelengths of
light okay i mean it's pretty easy to
imagine animals sensing that so the
example you use i guess is sunflowers
look like they have a bullseye in the
center to certain birds and bees
right that's right if you can see
ultraviolet light um then uh then yes uh
flowers look different uh the plumage of
many birds look different and some birds
that look um i identical across the
sexes to us actually look quite distinct
um to the birds themselves
but then there's also these wild
examples of completely different kinds
of senses like the mosquitoes sensing
co2 i don't i don't know if that counts
as
smell or how would how would we
characterize the fact that mosquitoes
know to find people by by sensing their
carbon dioxide emissions
so i think that is a very specific kind
of smell um but you know again it is a
um it is a form of smell that we don't
readily have access to and and does
stretch the imagination you know maybe
to the same extent as imagining an
ultraviolet bull's eye on on a flower um
might do you know you could imagine um
the the smell of someone's breath being
incredibly attractive rather than like
whatever we we think of as being
as our reaction to breath
um but you're right that there are um
other kinds of sensing that do seem
exotic and that really pushed the limits
of our imagination
so you know being able to sense the
magnetic field of the earth as many
songbirds and turtles can do
being able to sense electric fields as
many uh electric fish can do being able
to sense body heat as uh rattlesnakes or
vampire bats can um these all feel
much more alien you know it's not just
like the the sunflower example where you
you're essentially like swapping pallets
right you're just translating from
you know b vision to human vision
um but but do you think even
one of the extraordinary thing about the
centers i think is is that
even when you're thinking about um more
familiar senses so not like electro and
electroreception or magnetoreception the
ones that we just don't have even
something like vision that we have
it doesn't take
much to start getting into territory
that
challenges our imaginations in the same
way
um you know one
really easy example um
a duck that's sitting on a pond
because of the placement of its eyes
can see the entirety of the sky without
having to turn its head
i cannot imagine that i i can try but it
it feels hard and effortful you might
i'm so used to having my visual world be
right in front of me and be like you
know a 180 degree swath of space um
in directly in front of my head that
it's really really hard to imagine
seeing behind me you know to to imagine
walking in a straight line and have
parts of your visual world
recede away from you as well as while
another part goes towards you
that that feels very challenging do you
think and maybe this is something we
just don't know but do you think that
the brain of a duck
is literally different kind of hardware
to deal with that or is it maybe just a
software problem
[Music]
i think that um it's a bit of both
um and and i think the the hardware
piece of it becomes more obvious when
you think about something that is
like much more different to us than even
a dark so the example i give in the book
is is an octopus right and an octopus
has um a large nervous system but um
most of that nervous system exists in
its arms um its arms have have a large
number of neurons more collectively than
its actual that the brain in its head
does
and those neurons allow the arms to work
um
semi-autonomously the arms have a bit of
their own agency and they they can move
and do things independently of what the
main animal is doing and there's some
connection between those two things but
then when you think about the senses it
becomes even weirder because the arms
have um taste and touch receptors on the
suckers um and then the head does vision
obviously with the two eyes
um so you have this creature that
has this distributed nervous system
um and that's doing different kinds of
sensing with different parts of that
nervous system
so you know how do you put all of that
together
again it's it's very hard to imagine and
you know in the book i write about how
um throughout fantasy and science
fiction literature we have many examples
of people
who um you know project their
consciousness into the minds of other
animals um
and um this is like a very standard like
mythological trope but like my argument
is because the hardware is different it
just wouldn't work right like the the
you know
the mind and brain of a human uh have
evolved to process uh information that
comes in from the body of a human so you
can't just like you know shunt that into
the body of an octopus and expect that
to work in the sort of weird like you
know dualist way i i think that you know
the whole thing exists as a package and
must be understood as a package now that
that makes perfect sense to me and i
think what i'd like to do you know given
your book that is coming out by the way
i'll tell people the name of it it's
called an immense world how animal
senses reveal the hidden realms around
us and uh we go through in the book all
these senses both the familiar ones and
the less familiar ones and i want to do
that i want to hit some of the
highlights but but first i like what you
just said because it drives home the
fundamental fact that it's not just a
difference of degree right it's not just
a couple wavelengths here or there it's
a very different kind of sensing and you
have this wonderful
sentence uh in your book early on where
even if it's with the same senses that
we know about they can be deployed in
different ways so you say there are
animals with eyes on their genitals ears
on their knees noses on their limbs and
tongues all over their skin and you can
just imagine uh following thomas nagel
and what it is is it like to be a bat
that the
the the world of such a creature is just
a different kind of world even if it's
the same physical world even if you're
eating the same food and dining in the
dark uh your your reconstruction of it
inside your brain is an utterly alien
phenomenon
uh absolutely and i think um nagel was
uh very prescient and exactly right on
this there is a sort of fundamental
unknowability to that um
to that phenomenon for for exactly those
reasons you know the senses are
different the animal's body is different
it puts those senses together in in in a
different way um and and yeah even
part of the i think
part of the reason for writing this book
and part of why i'm interested in this
topic is it turns like even the most
familiar of ideas into things that feel
like unfamiliar and weird um you know so
so um you just listed a bunch of
examples of sense organs appearing in
different in different body parts so for
for humans taste is something we do with
our tongues um that exists in our heads
and partly that's because of our size
we're a medium-bodied animal and so the
food that we eat is of uh uh when we eat
we put food inside our heads um
if you are a very small animal like an
insect food can instead be something
that you land on and walk upon and for
that reason many insects from
butterflies to flies have taste
receptors on their feet so
a fly that's landing on the apple that
you're about to put in your mouth is
tasting that apple as it's walking
around it um
and and again like i think that truly
challenges your imagination you can just
about like you know if i'm touching like
um the the mattress that i'm sitting on
now you know if i i don't know what it
would be like to have
you know to be able to smell or taste or
have a chemical sense of that in the way
that a fly or an octopus might well and
it makes perfect sense because as i was
reading about taste in your book in some
sense the sense of taste comes too late
to be a good warning system right the
food is already in our mouth but for a
creature where taste is external that
can actually be useful information
before you start ingesting the stuff
yeah absolutely um you know for for us
like well you know even for us like
taste is is a quick warning system you
know if we if something tastes bitter we
can we can spit it out um but you know
if you if you're very small if you're if
you're a fly you can just take off um
this incidentally is is part of the
reason why deet works um you know deet
tastes repulsive to mosquitoes and if a
mosquito lands in an arm that's covered
with deet it tastes something foul and
takes off
good so it's not i guess i would have
thought it was smell but you're saying
it's really taste
well okay so
so i talk about this in the book right
the distinction between taste and smell
is actually quite
counterintuitive um and and hard to
explain to the extent that i even asked
like some biologists like what is the
difference between them and some of them
struggled for an answer you know i think
you can go through some of the obvious
guesses right like a
some people would say okay taste is
something that you do with your tongue
and
smell is something you do with your nose
but how does that work when you're a fly
and you're tasting with your feet or how
does that work with your snake which is
tasting with its tongue
um so it's not just about the organ some
people say it's about the the distance
of the stimuli so taste is about close
contact like um
sensing chemicals that are that you have
to make physical contact with that exist
in liquid or solid form whereas a smell
is about detecting chemicals floating
over long distances through the air but
again there are problems with that right
if you're an aquatic animal the
distinction between those two things
become like collapses into almost
nothingness
and even for smell those molecules are
dissolving in a liquid layer in your
nose so there's always a liquid phase
i think that the actual distinction
between them as um one person who
studies taste explained to me
is in their use um taste is a a
largely innate and inflexible sense that
is used
most almost entirely to work out if
something is good to eat or not
it's very simple and it's quite binary
it's like yes no um you know spit or
swallow um and um
and smell
is um more complex more dependent on
experience
and more more tailorable you know smell
depends on
your positive and negative experiences
would think with chemicals over the
course of your life
and animals put it to a very wide range
of uses from navigation to finding food
to social interactions um so you know
that that thing that the mosquito is
doing when it lands on a deep covered
arm and reflexively takes off falls very
much under the rubric taste it's the
kind of thing that taste um allows an
animal to do
i guess i would have intuitively thought
that my personal sense of taste is more
subtle and varied than my sense of smell
maybe i'm just not very good at smelling
things
well okay so
i think that's partly because
um
most of what we think of as taste is
actually smell like when we when we eat
food um that like sense of um like
having a refined palate to that sense of
connoisseurship of being able to
identify flavor
almost all of that is smell
all your taste buds are really giving
you is is the five basics right it's
sweet sour um
bitter uh salt and umami um you know the
the richness that we associate with
meals like a lot of the pleasure that we
derive from food is really about smell
it's about those those um you know
things hitting your nose as you're
putting food into your mouth or like
going up the back of the palate um uh
yeah it's it's it's interesting that
culturally
taste is the sense that we associate
with like connoisseurship right we talk
about people having like
fine tastes um whereas it's actually the
cruder and less sophisticated sense than
smell i guess i should have known that
are you familiar with ann sophie barwich
who is a philosopher
right yeah i know the name yeah he's a
philosopher of smell and she was a
previous uh guest on mindscape and you
know she she's a a champion of taking
smell more seriously and i should have
remembered that lesson from from talking
to her there's a lot going on that that
but
i mean actual let's just get into it
because we don't need to go in the order
that i was imagining things
smell and taste seem different
fundamentally to me than many of the
other senses we're going to talk about
which are kind of vibration based right
you know electrical electromagnetic
waves sound waves literal vibrations but
is
tell me if i'm wrong here but i get the
feeling that there's a molecular kind of
fit and luck and key mechanism going on
when we talk about the sense of taste
and smell
um yes um and and i caveat this by
saying that actually a lot of how a lot
of the details here are still um are
still unknown and so
certainly with smell there is very much
a lock and key thing there are receptors
um that are specially shaped that to
recognize different molecules around us
um and
those receptors uh you know are the sort
of fundamental lego bricks
that that our sense of smell operates on
but
you know the the
the universe of possible smells is huge
um
and um and certainly more vast than um
you know than than our like a genetic
repertoire of um odor receptors
and so there has to be this quite
complicated like combinatorial code that
goes from like the basic hardware to our
nose to like our ability to distinguish
between um this just huge universe of
possible odors um both individually and
in combination and smell is super
complicated and and a lot of that like
um you know that that that intermediate
step between like detect like
snagging a molecule from the air uh and
like shot you know shoving into another
molecule that recognizes its shape and
then you know what exists in our heads
like the aroma of baking bread and all
that that is still largely mysterious i
think um and you know that's that's for
us let alone for for other creatures do
you have an opinion uh especially after
writing this book about the claims of
wine connoisseurs to be able to pinpoint
you know
uh pencil shavings and apple rinds and
leather smells and tastes in a good
bottle of wine
so you know i i do think that um
[Music]
i i'm sure that there certainly are
people
who are very good at identifying
particular odors
and you know and and recognizing them
and i think this partly is a thing that
humans are just not very practiced at
you know it's the um
as as you said as others have noted um
uh
humans kind of deprioritize our sense of
smell like just culturally um you know
we it's it's um it's not a thing we have
a rich vocabulary for most of our words
for describing smell are borrowed from
other senses or they're just like nouns
you know like lemon um
uh and um and we we've sort of
underappreciated it and thus
underdeveloped it now i think a lot of
people have a much keeness and smell i
think a lot of people are better at
putting words to their experiences there
are even entire cultures of people
who have rich smell vocabularies
um
but um
you know i think the the the wine
question is interesting because while
i'm sure that it is possible to identify
specific smell components of it like the
the the this is very heavily tied into
the question of like
you know is an expensive bottle of wine
actually better right than than a cheap
buffalo wine nothing for that like there
have been a lot of trials showing that
that actually it's not the case right
like if you sort of blind um if you do
like a blinded experiment um you know
often like people can't tell the
difference between them into in terms of
like purported quality
um
but i want but i also feel like
this speaks to some of the malleability
of smell and and of our senses right
that we can um
that that it's also
a bit top down rather than bottom up
that it depends like on um our
experience also depends on like the
cultural value that we impart on these
things um
and so you know
one way of looking at the wine thing is
haha look at all these rubes thinking
that this wine that they've paid a lot
of money for is special but another
perhaps more generous way is
isn't there something like kind of cool
about the way our brains and senses are
constructed that you can take something
that is basically
unidentif actually indistinguishable
from something that's like
from from from another type of wine and
imbue it with what really really feels
to people like something special
you know my own feeling about those
studies is that they can't possibly be
studying people who are practiced and
trained to taste wine because it seems
to me it's a pretty
big difference between a fine bottle of
wine and a cheap one but i'd have to
look that up to be to be sure but but
certainly you know our training matters
and our context matters you know as you
say in the book um
precisely the same smell can be and then
sophie barbic said the same thing in in
our interview can be either repulsive or
attractive depending on its context
right it can it can be like cheese or
awful depending on how you encounter
that
smell yeah absolutely and you know
that's true
within humans um you know that for for
both reasons both cultural and genetic
you know there are some people with um
uh
genetic variants that mean that body
odor smells like vanilla um you know
very very lucky people i feel uh i feel
rather envious of them um but you know
and then those those differences become
even more
extraordinary across the animal kingdom
you know as a very basic example like my
dog typo um
is not repulsed by the smell of poop in
the same way that i might be um you know
of every
it's i think this is a good example
of um what the umvelt means like
different creatures vary in what smells
they have access to and then what those
smells mean to them
um and how those smells are used in
their life well and you do point out the
very important thing in the book that we
humans when taking our dogs for walks uh
deny them their own belt sometimes
because we're we don't understand that
they need to smell things let them smell
things that's their
lives right right it's it's such a
fundamental part of being a dog and you
know i think a lot of um dog owners not
knowing that pull dogs away from smell
experiences you know hurrying them along
on a walk um stopping them from sniffing
other dogs in the genitals because they
think it's indecorous for some reason um
i i do think that um
uh it's a problem right we there are
studies by people like alexandra
horowitz
who has many great books in dog
cognition about how um
dogs that are allowed to sniff and
encourage to sniff end up being
basically happier like less anxious more
optimistic
um because
they they just get to be dogs um you
know and uh and and i i encourage this
like i when when type and i go go out
for walks uh you know at least once a
day we have a walk that is his to
control um you know he gets to decide
how he wants to spend that time we don't
have a destination in mind we might you
know make it like one side of a block we
might go for uh you know we might go
further afield but
it's his control and what he does with
that time is he sniffs like really
intensely he he explores even
bits of street that you know we've
walked um we've walked along hundreds of
times over um you know i think like
that's that alone is is indication of
how important that smell that the sense
of smell is to dogs like if you give
them full agency the way they a lot of
them choose to exert that agency is by
sniffing everything yeah and i don't
claim to understand it at all i mean i
have two cats one of which will not want
you to scratch her until she has sniffed
you
your fingers thoroughly the other one
couldn't care less he's like yes
scritches i want them now
yeah right right right right and and
right there so there's there's species
level differences and there's absolutely
individual level differences too um you
know one thing that um
one thing that i've said a few times um
in talking about this book and and which
i plan on saying like as my disclaimer
in front of any q a in any um
in-person event is
i cannot tell you why your pet does that
weird thing that it does
it is as much a mystery to me as i'm
sure it is to you um but i think that
you know we
we can start
we we can start getting somewhere right
we can start thinking about the kinds of
hypotheses that make sense or the kinds
of things that
that that that we the kind of questions
we need to ask you know like so
you know i'll give you an example there
are some times when um
when typo looks out the main window um
of our living room and freaks out um
where he just like starts barking at the
window and it's not when and and you
know sometimes it's obvious right
sometimes like someone's around the
doorbell there's someone like loud
there's a loud van driving past but
sometimes
we don't know why he does it
and like
you know
like watching that firstly like gives me
a lot more sympathy for people who
believe in things like ghosts for
example like paranormal stuff because
um if you're not used to thinking about
animals as existing in a completely
different sensory world then if they are
reacting to something you can't sense
that's can't be natural it's going to be
supernatural right um but like i think
if you're used to thinking about um
vaults then you can start asking
questions like okay is there like a
vibration out there that i'm not feeling
um is there a um high-pitched noise that
exists beyond the level of my hearing
but that typo can hear you know are
there smells drifting in through the
cracks in the window that are freaking
him out like is it a weird shape that
like my much sharper eyes can can
identify as something innocuous but that
he has somehow like um mistaken for a
threat um i might never know the answers
but at least but i think those are the
right kinds of questions to be asking
and they flow from this understanding of
the different sensory worlds of other
animals well and we have a lot of senses
to cover here so um you've already
mentioned that human beings are pretty
good at vision i mean we're pretty
vision centered in our lives i think we
sort of as you already said the
vocabulary that we use even to describe
other senses is often borrowed from
vision so let's talk about that a little
bit you did discuss this
uh
maybe it's a theory maybe it's pretty
obviously true of how eyes develop over
evolutionary time through different
stages first just sensing the existence
of light and then moving on maybe i'll
let you tell the story
right and this is i think this is
certainly pretty well accepted among um
vision scientists um you know it's it's
the idea is very very reputable and and
well respected team but but it sort of
goes along
four stages that um first you have
simple light-sensitive cells um that do
nothing more than detect the presence of
light and that's very useful for animals
that want to for example
find um uh
for animals that want to sense like the
time of day you know you could see
imagine like an aquatic simple animal um
that's that's reacting to the presence
or absence of light um then the next
step is is also pretty simple all you do
is add some kind of shade to your light
sensitive cell so maybe it's a
a dark membrane or a spot of pigment and
what that does is it blocks light coming
in from a certain direction which means
that now you not only can sense light
but you can tell which direction it's
coming from and that allows you to do
another more like a an expanded class of
things including like crawling towards
shade um finding like protection and
shelter
then the next step up if you take a lot
of those shaded cells and you put them
together then suddenly you have the
ability to sense an image um you know a
low resolution image at first but then
that gives you the ability to do more
stuff in the world around you um you
know beyond just like
head towards dark area
and then the fourth stage is when you
add like focusing elements to that when
you add things like lenses like
basically deluxe features that turn um
what might be a very blurry image into a
sharper one and that's where how you end
up with the kind of eyes that we have um
and you know that allow us to do with
vision all the things that we do
reading um you know looking at each
other's other spatial expressions like
things that involve um
high resolution
um and yeah i think that this this
something a few things that are notable
about this pathway like we have examples
of animals that exist at every point
along that that spectrum um and and so
you know darwin lamented this idea that
um our eyes seemed perfect and he it was
hard to imagine how they the gradual
steps by which they evolved but we now
have those steps we have those steps in
theory and in practice
um but also
you know darwin was wrong i think in
saying that in thinking of our eyes as
this sort of perfect exemplar right like
there's no destination eye that animals
were sort of evolving to words um
all of those eyes on those intermediate
strips exist because they are very well
suited to their crew their owner's needs
um you know starfish is pretty simple
eyes um on the tips of his arms which he
can use to find the shelter of a wreath
but that's what that's all it needs to
do you know a starfish doesn't need an
eagle's eye it doesn't even have to spot
prey from miles away um uh but an eagle
does so in many ways i think the eye is
is a great example of evolution tuning
and animal senses to the needs of its
owners well and a point you also make in
the book is that
having good senses requires resources
there's there's reasons not to be
perfect at all the senses because you
know we have we have to give and take
what we can given the amount of energy
and and space in our bodies and brains
we want to devote to these senses
right totally and i think that may be i
i think that can be a counterintuitive
idea um in part because
you know a lot of sense organs are
basically holes right so it's very easy
to think of them as like passive
receptacles you know like the the
the eyes um absorb light like sound goes
in through the ears we are they said the
these scent organs become like these
these sort of vacuums that that soak up
stimuli in the world around us but you
know for any of them to work um it takes
a surprising amount of energy like even
getting the neurons in the retina
ready to fire at the moment when light
sensitive cells detect light um they
need to be you know perpetually set
in this state of um in in the state of
excitement you know
the analogy i give is it's like um it's
like you're drawing a bow
um and knocking an arrow
and holding it there always
so that at the moment when you could
fire the arrow you it's ready um that's
what like the nervous system that that
operates our senses um is doing all the
time
and so to have that in place
takes a considerable amount of energy so
even when i'm closing my eyes even if
i'm sitting in the dark
having good eyes um drains my resources
and it means that there's always going
to be trade-offs it means that um
no animal is going to be able to sense
everything because it has energetic
limits but also no animal needs to sense
everything and you know and that's
partly why
umvals exists at all
um it's because
um evolution has tailored the animal
sent in animal senses to the needs of
its owners you know according to the
limits of its energy budget
well and
there's another layer of sophistication
right because you know the story you
told about the development of eyes up to
the focusing and so forth
is kind of parallel to how we would
imagine a really good camera being
developed uh but
eyes have this extra thing where the
different photoreceptors are used for
different purposes like rods and cones
in our eyes at a very basic level but
then
am i you're going to correct me if i get
this wrong but jumping spiders have
different eyes for motion versus sharp
vision uh this is just a whole other
level of uh elaborateness i think
right right you know we so we have um
different parts of our eye that are
devoted to different tasks um so we have
um uh the center of our retina just off
the center the the fovea
is where our vision is sharpest you know
it's why um when i'm looking at you
right now um i can see your face in
detail um whereas if i look off to the
side even a little bit now your face is
blurry in my field of vision even though
i can still see it um
a jumping spider has something similar
except it has fully like it has done
this full division of labor thing
between its sets of eyes um so that the
center pair of four pairs does sharp
details of vision
and the pair just to lie the sides of
that the lateral center the lateral pair
do does movement detection yeah and
that's just
crazy to me um you know you can i've
watched experiments being done where the
lateral eyes have been blocked and you
move like the shape of a cricket in
front of the spider and the spider
cannot track it you unblock those eyes
and suddenly the lateral eyes are
telling the middle eyes where to go and
the spider is following the cricket
that's
how do you even begin imagining what
what that might be like i mean i assume
that for the spider this all fuses into
like a single stable unified visual
experience like it does for my eyes with
those sort of do different jobs existing
in different parts of the same eye but
like like is it you know that the fact
that they are separate does absolutely
blow my mind i'll give i'll give you
another example right like so um
uh
color vision exists throughout
throughout my retina it's sort of best
in the fovea but you know i'm looking
around me and everything i see is is in
color but you have like larval fish
where um
the part of the retina that that sort of
that's pointing upwards is monochrome so
it's really only seeing in black and
white uh a part that is facing um
forward uh and and a little bit down uh
is sensing mainly you ultraviolet to
pick out its prey against this
ultraviolet fog of the water and there's
another part that is doing
tetrachromatic color vision so that's
seeing like more another dimension of
color beyond what we can see so you have
the same eye that's doing three
different kinds of color vision
in the eye of like a baby fish
um again i i cannot imagine what that
that would be like well clearly the
brain
knitting together all of these signals
is a very very important part of this
whole story i remember being very struck
stricken struck by david eagleman
telling me that if you if you watch
someone dribble a basketball walking
away from you
eventually you know it takes longer for
the sound to get to you than the light
so they will become out of sync but for
a long time they remain in sync because
the brain puts them into sync even
though it's taking the sound uh longer
to get to use there's a certain point at
which they suddenly go out of sync
because the brain says all right i give
up
yeah absolutely and that piece of it
is very very hard to get at you know we
can just about get at it with humans
right it's really hard and that that's
the sort of that's the nagel thing that
like even if you
even if you you know you can do all the
the fancy experimentation you want but
um that that final piece like how the
brain knits that together into something
subjective and cohesive is
is is a little ineffable um you know so
one example right like so bats
echolocate bats send out high frequency
calls and they um hear the rebounding
echoes and through that they can sense
the world around them they can navigate
through obstacles capture insects yadda
yadda um
because of the nature of that sense um
echolocation should be stroboscopic um
you know the bat is putting out a call
it is hearing the echo it is putting
another call it is hearing the echo
every set of call and echo creates a
snapshot of the world around it um so it
should be like the equivalent of
watching a movie right where you have
different frames um each depicting
something static now when we watch a
movie we obviously knit together those
frames into
something that makes sense to us right
you're into into into a sense of
movement and into like this cohesive
moving world um
i assume that that is what bats do
you know i i don't imagine that a bat
sense of the world as it flies and
echolocates is like you know
this strobe thing
but
i don't know that
um it's just an educated guess and
partly like it's an educated guess i can
make in part because like a bat is a
mammal it has a brain like you know
smaller but not entirely dissimilar to
to what i have so it's not hard to
imagine that it has like the right like
um processing power to to create that
like cohesive movie from all those
snapshots that might be very different
if you were thinking about something
that had um a much smaller or simpler
brain
well and uh even in the in the case of
vision our brain is doing a lot when it
comes to color right we haven't talked
about color yet except you briefly
mentioned the tetrochromatic aspect of
things uh for some animals but
to a physicist you know we think that we
understand what color is it's the
wavelength of light but of course almost
everything we're looking at has multiple
wavelengths coming at us and our eyes
filter it just down to
three i guess three sort of filter
windows astronomers are very familiar
with this but then our brain have to
reproduce or reconstruct what it
actually seems like as a color to us and
it's probably very different to
different animals
yeah totally um you know a
wavelength of uh what is it like 700
nanometers
feels like red to us
um but it's not necessarily red to a
another creature um you know might to to
typo my dog um it's going to be
closer to like a kind of dark muddy
yellow um because he has a different um
setup he has a different set of hardware
in his eyes um yeah like you know this
color i think is interesting because it
is it really is fundamentally inherently
subjective there's nothing specific
about 700 nanometers that makes it red
it's red because that's what
we that's what our
um our sense organs and our brains um
you know that's the sensation that our
nervous system creates
um and that's going to be very different
from for other animals so you know for a
dog um the visual spectrum goes from uh
you know kind of a dark yellow to a dark
blue and in the middle where we have
green um they just have like whites and
grays
um and
um for a for a bird um
it's going to be a lot more complicated
it's going to go from red to ultraviolet
um but you know again like
i'm talking about the visual spectrum as
if it was a linear thing and and it
isn't it's not just like
it's like it's not that birds with it
with an extra type of color sensitive
cone in their eyes like push out the
spectrum and its margins is that they
have this whole other dimension of color
that we don't have access to so you can
imagine that an animal that that only
has um one or zero cones types of
chromosomes eyes can see like a hundred
gradations from black to white and all
the shades of gray in between um if you
add another class like so you get what
typo has you add another hundred
gradations um between blue and yellow
that sort of multiply onto those so now
you're talking um about um a heart like
10 000 um different possible
discriminable colors um if you add uh
another type of console we have then you
add 100 gradations from red to green um
on top of that too and then if you add
what a bird has you add another you know
it's all multiplicative um
and that's why
that
visual world of a bird is so difficult
to imagine like if you have another
animal like say b which is also
trichromatic it's you know the b just
sees like a different part of the
spectrum it just goes from like green to
ultraviolet you can sort of recolor what
we see into like what the b might see
but you absolutely can't do that with a
bird because just four into three what
doesn't go
um and so
it's really really hard to imagine what
a bird might see um you know you can say
like here is a particular type of color
that a bird sees and i don't see i can
recolor like parts of the world that i
have to match that to show what a bird
where a bird might see it but you can't
do that with like
with with all of the bits all of the
colors that the bird has access to
but all that uh taking into
consideration you're still a little
deflationary about the mantis shrimp
which is very famous on the internet for
seeing all sorts of colors
and you're saying it's it's been
exaggerated a little bit
right so manta shrimps have um 12 or
more types of color sensing cells in in
their eyes right so so people are like
um oh do they have like um are they what
is it dodeca chromats right um you know
do they do they have this like 12
dimensional television and the the
answer seems to be no in fact in terms
of discriminating between different
colors they seem to be substantially
worse than humans or you know fish or
like basically anything else that's been
tested
and it seems that what they're doing
like people's best guess of what they're
doing is that um
okay so in our eyes we're taking the
outputs from three kinds of cone cells
um and
doing like quite basic arithmetic
between them like adding and subtracting
those signals in a process called
opponency and that is how we go from
three to like the millions of possible
colors that we can see
uh a mantis shrimp probably isn't doing
that it seems to be taking the raw
signals from its type 12 types of color
cells
and just sending them straight to the
brain and then comparing them to a kind
of look-up table this is apparently what
satellites do
and it's very different to what like
basically all other animals do with
color rather than like having this
12-dimensional spectacular rainbow in
its eyes it basically seems to be
collapsing the entirety of of the visual
spectrum into what what tantamount's
like a children's coloring book right
it's it's 12 different types of area
that each get a different color and then
you're sort of passing the world um in
in that way um and which i think is the
the opposite of the reputation that they
have but also like very cool still
well look it's a shrimp we shouldn't
judge it too harshly it doesn't have a
lot of processing power in the brain
right right and and and so this is right
and this takes us back to the point
where um
the size of the brain matters right like
you can have as much uh like
an animal with a brain the size of a
mantis shrimp
really shouldn't have the processing cap
capacity necessary to deal with like 12
dimension collar vision and and it it
turns out
it doesn't right so so um
it all goes it all goes hand in hand the
the senses are not just about what
exists in the center organ like vision
isn't just about the retina it's also
about what the brain does with the
signals from that retina
okay again lots of senses to cover here
so let's move on to right touch i'm
going to count vibrations in with touch
right i mean in some sense touch is a a
very direct thing we're touching things
but then again
one of the points you make in the book
is that other kinds of animals have in
some sense extended touch they use the
medium they're in whether it's air or
water or whatever to
for all intents and purposes touch
things that they're not touching
yeah yeah right right yes and i think
that is um you know a bit
counterintuitive right we can do that to
an extent you know i have a as a ceiling
fan going uh blowing now you know i can
feel the current from that fan but that
kind of touch of the distance is very
much par for the course for a lot of
other creatures um so you know a
um a
shore bird probing into the sand um can
detect objects buried in the sand that
are beyond the reach of its bill by
sensing the ways the pressure waves
created by the probing bill are
deflected by objects in the sand um you
know fish
and manatees can sense the currents
created by other things swimming in the
water around them um
and and they can use that to navigate uh
their environments to sense each other
you know even a fish that is that even a
blind fish can school successfully
without bumping into its um into its
neighbors
because of this scent um a seal um
has whiskers that allow it to detect the
trails left behind by swimming fish that
still exist in the water after that fish
is gone and that's kind of that that's
wild to me right like you
um
i don't think
before writing this book i would never
have thought of a fish as leaving a
track right um but but it does it leaves
behind um turbulent water that continues
to roil long after the fish is gone and
that an animal with the right equipment
like a seal with its whiskers can follow
um
you know even in the air there are
examples of this too um there are um you
know you have um uh things like crickets
and spiders that can detect um the
ludicrously faint air currents created
by other um critters in you know around
them there are spiders that can detect
the the wind created by a fly
precisely enough to then leap into the
air and catch that fly you know there
are there are crickets that can sense
the breeze created by a charging spider
enough to run away from it um
and it really does seem like a lot of
these creatures are are like pushing
against the limits of physics um you
know they are their sense organs are
about as sensitive as they could
possibly be
and i certainly cannot imagine what it
is like to be a cricket for exactly
these reasons right i mean the world is
a different place seems like a different
place
you're i guess the right way to say it
is the world is the world but
you're sensitive to such a different
part of the world that it might as well
be a different place
yes yes exactly you know if you were if
you were in the in the same room as a
cricket
you would be sharing the same physical
environment but you would both have a
radically different experience of that
environment and that is is very much
like the core of what an immense world
is about and this is again skipping
ahead a little bit but it absolutely
reminds me of the electrical fish which
you talk about and i actually had
malcolm macgyver on the podcast uh
talking about such things and
i i love you have a little picture in
the book of this fish which has its
electric field around it and
an insulating object versus a conducting
object versus a high capacitance object
all appear different to the fish that it
just able to extend its electric field a
little bit around it
yeah um and and again like uh like how
how wild right so so um electric so the
electric sense um
more than any of
so more than any other sense i think
touch is the closest analog for the
electric sense um you know the electric
sensor occurs across uh over an electric
fisher's entire body it it's it's again
in like an extended form of touch it
goes for about
an inch beyond the surface of the fish's
skin
and it is sensitive to different
qualities of the environment that we
don't care about so you talked about
like conductivity um you know
capacitance um these are these are you
know i guess what to and what to an
electric fish what things like
brightness um or color might be like to
us um you know what things like volume
and pitch would be to our ears
um i i think that the
the thing that really blows my mind
about the electric sense
is that
so these fish are producing their own
electric fields and they they're sensing
the way those bills are distorted by
objects around them that's how they can
make their way through water which is
often too murky to
to see
but those exact same pulses are also
messages that they use to communicate to
other fish
so for them the line between perception
and communication is very blurry
um when electric fish fight
sometimes um the loser will
convey submission by
ceasing its electric field um you know
basically like someone just sort of
shutting up and backing away from a
fight right and closing their eyes
because that is right right exactly
right but because that is the same field
it uses to navigate
it's also as if someone is losing a
fight
you know keeping quiet but also like
covering its eyes and ears and backing
away right the fish becomes oblivious to
its surroundings in the act of um of of
of um ceasing its communication
uh and
that that's really weird that's the
target that's hard to think about it's
hard to think about as a writer and
reader of this book but it's also hard
to think about as a scientist studying
these fish right
what if you watch the animal doing a
thing
what is what is that what is it doing
like is it is it communicating is it
doing something like perceptual is it
doing something communicative a bit of
both and neither right we it's it's hard
to know or is this distinction even
relevant if you're a fish
yes exactly exactly
and
even though i mean as you said and i
also sort of latched on to there's
absolute similarities between this
electrical sense the fish has and
this extended sense of touch that we
have from from vibrations in water or
air or whatever it is
more alien to us human beings we don't
have any electrical sense roughly
speaking right
yes i think that's true um well i mean
you know i can sense an electric field
kind of right if i like lick a battery
or if i like stick my finger in in this
in the socket i will i will feel
something but it's
it's gonna suck and it requires like a
lot of stimulus for that to happen like
the the these animals put electric
fields to subtle
um you know and and everyday use in a
way that yeah absolutely we we cannot do
um i think that
that's that's challenging to our own
imagination for a lot of ways like
partly we just don't have the sort of
analog of it but but we're also limited
in our vocabulary right like when we're
when we're talking about what an
electric fish feels we're talking about
things like capacitance and um potential
like things that um that where that
feels just a bit like cold and abstract
that isn't like the rich lexicons that
we have to describe things that we see
or smell or hear um and you know that
it i think it's a good example where the
limits of our own senses and the limits
thus of our like language and our style
of thought um it acts as a barrier to
really appreciating what these other
creatures are experiencing do you know
of any science fiction writers who have
imagined aliens that have electrical
senses and have invented a whole new
vocabulary for them to just you know
describe the oh that's a capacitance
object over there it must be alive maybe
it's tasty
right right i i bet there are i'm sure
there are um i just don't know any of
any of them off the top of my head so if
anyone's listening to this and can think
of an opportunity sci-fi
receptive sci-fi let me know well and
the other thing is because we don't have
it it is more mysterious to us i mean
you do a very good job in the book for
every sense
you discuss literally the sort of
biochemical way in which it is activated
you know the proteins that help us
revision and so forth but
how does that work for the electrical
sense and i'm not going to give away the
the punch line but you point out it all
stems from hair cells at the end of the
day
right yeah um
right right like um
it's it's very strange that um so
you know we talked about this
distributed sense of of fish um being
able to touch at a distance that that's
their lateral line and it comes down to
um you know small hair cells that they
have in their bodies um you know
fundamentally like most forms of touch
come down to this right it's like a
small structure that gets deflected um
and
and you know some neural setup that can
detect that deflection that is how um
most uh you know most touch operates and
you put that
thing in a capsule you've got the
pressure sensor uh you put it on skin
you have something to conduct like water
and air currents you put that in an ear
and it's something that can now detect
sound waves channeled into the air
that's basically how hearing works
and you can turn
so the electroreceptors
that electric fish use to detect their
own electric fields um
evolve from those same types of cells so
in many ways electric the electric
sensor really is
a a very specialized form of touch um so
you know you talked about like wanting
to to um
to to talk about touch and vibrations
and all the rest in in the same category
like if you were go if you were to be
like super lumper about all of this like
all of these senses are basically the
same thing you know they like touch
vibrations uh hearing um you know
echolocation advanced form of hearing
electroreception they all feel like just
extensions of the same kind of
mechanical sense uh you also have all
these other wonderful senses i mean i'm
i'm lumping a couple of senses together
like like we did with with touch and uh
electricity but
heat
and pain are listed as senses in your
book i don't think of pain as a sense
usually right but uh i guess it is and
and you do a pretty good job of
distinguishing between
nociception which i guess is the actual
sense versus pain which is an experience
something that the conscious brain sort
of uh feels after the fact
yes and and um right so how to deal with
this was actually a challenge in the
book because um it's kind of a mishmash
sense right with the type most of the
book is organized by stimuli like
there's a there's a chapter on the
chapter and hearing is really a chapter
about sound the chapters on on light and
color are really on vision and color are
really chapters about light um but but
pain um is about detecting all kinds of
things that are united by their capacity
to cause us harm
um so you know some of that might be
chemical um it might be um detecting
noxious temperature so extreme heat or
extreme cold
so how how you deal with that is um is
an interesting question and eventually i
decided like it was just worth putting
it in a separate chapter of its own
because
it does have this interesting
distinction a lot of scientists talk
about nociception which is the detection
of the harmful stimulus um and pain
which is the emotional response to that
detection so you know i touch a hot uh a
hot pan
and my finger recoils before i realize
what has happened that's nociception
that reflexive detection of the hot
stimulus um
pain is the suffering pain is the the
fact that that incident sucks
and that i i continue um being in
anguish afterwards um
there this distinction is interesting
because a lot of people
use it as a way of denying the idea that
animals can experience pain that they
have this sort of emotional reaction to
to to harm that they only do the
nociception bit and not the pain bit and
this discussion this question of whether
animals can do pain they have the
emotional experience their company's
nociception is a huge part of that
chapter you know i talk about
live debates about fish and insects and
crustaceans um and cephalopods um
but i think that
it's important to get i think it was
important to me to get that quite early
on in the book because
some people have argued that so i i
actually think that um things like fish
and and uh and certainly fish and
cephalopods um have uh can experience
pain they it might be exactly the same
as what we experience but it is um
certainly like of a kind um
but
um some people have argued that this
distinction is is is meaningless even in
the pain literature because for example
vision scientists are making a
distinction between photo reception the
detection of light and vision the
subjective thing right it's only when
we're talking about an area that affects
like the welfare of animals and like our
own morals and like what we can eat that
we draw the distinction i actually think
that line of argument is is wrong
because as we've said like vision
scientists absolutely do make a
distinction between those two things you
know there is basic photoreception they
do draw a line when like something
actually starts counting as an eye or
starts counting as true vision
um
why
so the distinction exists
the reason why it matters for pain is
that it it feeds into all of these moral
and ethical and even economic debates um
so you know trying to trying to get
readers to appreciate like this
distinction between like objective and
subjective um it pain the chapter and
pain i think gives us an insight into
like the fundamental unknowability in
this that we've already talked about and
that nagel um
pinpointed yeah and there's some
incommensurability i mean the the fish
or the shrimp or whatever feels
something and and whether or not it's
pain might not be an
answerable question in some philosophic
sense but
bringing up these moral ethical other
questions i will i promise this is the
last question but i do want to give you
an opportunity to talk about the issues
raised in the last chapter of the book
that we human beings because we don't
sense things in the same way that other
animals do have been willy-nilly
polluting their sensoria with light and
sound and and all sorts of other things
and we are really
making the earth a worse place for other
animals in various ways that
aren't very necessary like we could do a
better job
we could um we we flood the environment
with light especially at night where um
and um you know breaking like this
several billion year
hot streak that the world had of cycling
between light and dark we flood the
world with noise um we drown out alarm
calls and mating songs um and you know i
think all of this does harm to the
animals around us um
i think it harms us too it disconnects
us from the the um the nature that that
we're surrounded by disconnects us from
the the cosmos you know it um it's
really hard to see the stars at night
and and um you know most people um uh
who live where we live have never seen
the milky way before um
i think that's i think that's profoundly
sad and it it comes from our own belt
you know the fact that we don't think of
these things as pollutants but they very
much are to other creatures and i think
that they are pollutants that we can
remedy relatively easily you know it's
not like a place it's not like plastics
in the environment that are going to
persist for centuries it's not like ddt
and other pesticides that are similarly
going to
wend their way through the world long
after all all of us listening to this
are gone
um you want to fix light and noise
pollution often you can just flip a
switch and it disappears um it's a it's
a easy ecological win
and one that i think we should um try
and try and fix
and even if you don't know what it's
like to be a bat we can at least try to
be nicer to the bats and let them enjoy
their own belts absolutely we can give
the bats more space to be bats um you
know i think that's a worthy cause
that's a perfect uh closing thought so
ed young thanks very much for being on
the windscape podcast
thanks sean good to speak to you take
care
[Music]
you